there's a lot of protocol involved with
meeting the queen and one thing that
really stuck with me
was
uh they said that the queen really
disliked
walking into a room and having
everybody stop talking
prince philip came in first and in comes
the queen queen elizabeth
like there she is right there 15 feet
from you and as predicted
everybody stopped
so i turned to the gentleman beside me
and said no no keep talking tell the guy
next to you i don't care what you say
tell them what you had for breakfast
then i turned to the other guys and keep
talking come on let's keep talking let's
stay calm let's keep talking keep
talking
she was brought around to our group
um and introduced to everyone and she
asked me personally why did you choose
to come here and i
it was remarkable you were standing
there next to the sovereign she made me
feel very very comfortable looked at me
directly and you got the sense of
genuine curiosity
and i was just
i think just trying to stay in the
moment and mindful of all the protocol
because the gentleman who had done all
the protocol every time he said
something would look over at me and i
was like what what i promise i won't do
anything stupid in front of the queen
[Music]
i genuinely felt like she was interested
in what people had to say she was only
81 back then but still doing the
hundreds of engagements
and i got into a taxi and the taxi
driver commented you look very lovely
you have a very pretty dress on a school
i actually
i just met the queen
and he said you know people live to be a
hundred and never get to meet the people
and that's why i think it really hit me
what a
what a monumentous moment it was
you don't have to be a monarch you don't
have to be british clearly
to respect a sense of duty and
commitment to a nation she spent her
entire life serving the nation
you